I know you're armed to the teeth I'm
saying though what if we flip it and now
you have a bandolier of throwing
harmonicas I you can play them like kind
of like you know like what you already
have this well I mean you can throw them
like yeah the key is that here's a
harmonica I see now if you look at the
front of it it's kind of almost like a
blading these are the corner that's the
business end right there use one of
these give it a nice little flat throw
we just ended me right now just right
through the eyes he goes and let me tell
you something I'm razor precise with
this thing Jay something from o.9 we
went through the documentary swiped lean
through yeah yeah we through it it's
gonna be a to partner but we're having
fun with it turns out though show a lot
longer than not be seen in eighth grade
he's saying they're all I was trying to
be liked by the audience yeah but I I
wasn't like
I just hoped everyone liked me and then
my friends were like kind of the bad
kids so I just didn't want to get
bullied by them I just think there was a
thing as part of growing up that would
look if people went too far with
everything obviously it was gluttony and
everything but I mean just like bullying
and the loosest usage of the term just
sort of regulated things well tell you
what hey they also clean every board's
emissions if you're a fat kid I don't
know if it's important for everybody to
go it doesn't matter
you're beautiful you're an amazing
person doesn't matter everything well
also for your health you should probably
not be affecting brought that up with
the plus-size model industry where
they're like praising these women that
are you said dangerously overweight yeah
they're moderately hot every one of them
you said what Christine I saw an ad the
other day that got me really upset like
I think it'd be like putting an anorexic
woman up as a model and saying this is
beautiful I mean oh this is a sickness
this person needs help yeah you know or
a drug addict like it's crazy yeah but
you also know I mean with anorexic girl
you're like sad and bummed out but I
would like a really heavy girl you're
probably like catty and that food
you know she needs a little shot the
chops little I mean what everyone goes
obese girl oh you know she needs a
little boo bet he goes I know how to
happily that's one of the funniest
things I've ever I thought about that 20
minutes after him leaving I was still
every day Amy I guess you can act like
you can't heckle Florence to watch
bullying me fast we never really went
into that because John walked in know
they're that much do you have you
yeah it's dangerous it's absolutely
dangerous and it's somebody promoting
beauty will see a pillowcase full of
Dimes oh she's trying to find a coin
store machine to get rid of it's like a
clump suit it's zero zero to 40 which
it's fine it's not like women that are
size 40 shouldn't have clothes to buy
it's just a weird thing to normalize her
cankles are the finished thing on her
body but yours yeah you're saying like
they show this and they're like hey this
is suppose I was like hey do you need
help you are you and oh do you have a
food addiction like Cole this number
yeah it shouldn't be modeled as like yes
bitch be bitch be so unhealthy be have
tingly feelings in your own get the
bottoms of those feet round do you like
having strokes in your thirties then be
big the bad bitch do you sweat butter if
you love it do you have memory loss
because your hearts over okay pass out
let's go be bad you big bitch do you
like chocolate so much you don't give a
about the right side of your face
if you woke up driving a car be big and
beautiful are your utensils not big
enough yeah does your piss smell like a
bag of sugar are you in 24/7 disappoint
it's like a way it's like the way booze
like beer commercials eventually in the
90s had to start being like please drink
responsibly have you ever thought why
don't they make socks wider suffocating
you big beautiful bad bitch
did you Christopher a dog Bichon Frise
was on the couch did you find a remote
in a fall be big beautiful did your
niece run a thread trying to make you a
friendship necklace yeah but it is man
it's like the way that the beer
commercials were like back in the 80s
like drunk please drink responsibly when
it turns out this just rots your
liver yeah yeah it's not feeding alcohol
to party animals there's no such thing
as a party animal doing the aging
process alcohol the way we can when
Jagermeister call me on that tour say no
jokes Patrick and irresponsibly
or any thing sexual and alcohol-related
crazy
that's how Guinness was when I worked
for do sex jokes if I go if I even went
she came over we had a few drinks like
just like something like that and
they're like no no yeah they did a thing
where you could this girl this joke
all you like but do not give her alcohol
but you do it she better be stoned sober
you better enjoy the ride of Jager but
she better be stayed sober those things
go together a lot
why have you found the founder too much
alcohol and sex to be problematic
straddle the billion dollar fine line
it's been a thing it's been a problem
man we can't but drink response to demo
Cinco de Maya it was weird to work for a
large alcohol company because they were
like here's what you can and cannot say
like you cannot say this or you'll lose
your job and I wasn't trying to go back
to anything I know you but it's a it's a
only there one thing I can I draw a
picture like I draw a picture of
Mohammed like yeah absolutely do you
want to like it you should probably
I don't think I want to do that at all I
got drama home is squeezing tits and
just old deck and beg Teddy's
like I say like I've had too many I had
so many Guinness he look good do not say
that do not say you dragon of Guinness
to the cartoon transit how about I
drank enough Guinness to draw Muhammad
yes still no now this already a sober
act sorry dude I would never do that
sober and you're drinking Guinness you
just better be in a nice fog covered
field and a wagon and an itchy sweater
with two of your Irish friends laughing
and drinking ah dude it's so funny to
see who's like because there's people
that are like into Guinness and I was
like the Guinness ambassador you look
about a list of Guinness myths there's
so many grisly there's fish fish gel in
it they said that I've always heard
there's meat in the bottom of the barrel
right now me it's rats in the barrel
that has to be a certain way well I met
Fergal Murray the brewmaster of Guinness
and it was quite a toy and was covered
in rats like a Tory podium he was all
rats in a man suit okay what if I told
you that they came together like Voltron
it was made of her 700 rad fun
fascinating that's actually the new
Guinness point the old point is a mess
Guinness is good for you well it's
alcohol Guinness is black it's North I
know it wasn't black
yeah dude it was pretty good more for
like Guinness cures cancer some like
they used it's funny to see you all
there we know we're talking about
commercials this is what led us to here
but all the old commercial ones look up
old Guinness commercials because they're
like Guinness give you strength that's
how they marketed it they're like do you
have a long day at work
drink a cup of Guinness the Irish
workforce has alcoholism out of control
I'm not stupid to think wasn't their ads
for cigarettes saying like their
benefits for you yeah back in like the
30s and 40s and
they said like smoking look it up it's
what Bo said like finding out your
therapist headed Twitter you start
hacking up and coughing and having a lot
of stuff pretty few months in the
smoking like did anyone ever make an ad
for it like months into it that
Oh guys you know what like I don't know
if it is not let's not look at the
printout
yo you when you start smoking your well
I'm saying how many months in before
you're like who I actually I'm feeling
smoking not many and so I have to have
commercials at all like this is good for
you there's no you if you're smoking you
already know that's this sucks
within five years of smoking no matter
how many commercials are on do you feel
it when you breathe it go it's a problem
now but was this the mindframe different
really like it's not a problem that's
actually strike those are strengths
wheezes there she loves for strength
Guinness for strength so just drink this
and get strong there's a you drink
enough but you think you could lift
anything though Christine can you look
up which country I believe it's uh it
might be in like Bermuda or something
where there's a myth that if you drink
Guinness Extra Stout it's good for like
your potency for your like make a
shot on the nuts and appoint a Guinness
will make any load bar you a strong boy
if you drink enough you'll come all
right now I'm gonna drink this Guinness
and you just smack me in the nuts ready
go I'll tell you why I hate it I don't
like any beer that's not carbonated I
don't even understand it though what you
mean that swamp water that they had me
drinking for two years I don't
understand
was actually delicious enjoyed it was I
did I enjoy
I like Guinness so I was fine with it
you know there did get a point where I
didn't like it if I was what I was
drinking three a night three shows a
night yeah so that's nine Guinness sure
and then it's going out drinking with
the crew afterwards Guinness for
Guinness I had no dude I would sneak bud
Heavy's really yeah I got caught by my
boss that Guinness like a Budweiser
original I went to the bar at the hotel
in Ireland when we were there like
drinking in Dublin and I went down and
had a shot of Jack Daniel's and
Budweiser and the guy from Guinness I
came out was like oh what do you do I
was like ha ha ha I just have to check
and see if to them one suck so much this
is gross ass rice beer and then the
whole time I was like sweet delicious
like a gerbil at a water thing used to
be taking a little bit of you guys you
have a shop and I are gonna goes good Oh
disgusting it's just terrible I'm doing
it oh my
I'm punishing myself and so
sadomasochistic I only started taking a
little more of the shot it's oh god it's
so gross I'm not savoring or anything
I'm just really I'm relishing and how
gross it is when I when I tried I tried
quitting drinking one time and I got
like five weeks and I felt really good
about it and this is before I read the
book the easy way to quit drinking it
was like I felt really great about it
and then they're like hey Guiness wants
you to do ten more cities it was like
you know you know you know that point
where you're like making money off
comedy but if you don't have another
side job it's it's hard it's like really
hard so I was at that point where I was
headlining not making a lot of money at
all on the weekends and then trying to
do this thing and I was like I'll do ten
more cities but I'll try not to drink
for some reason I thought I did I didn't
have to drink I was like I can go put
some ice tea in my cup no just do a fake
sip just like take it alright the first
night we're in Boston I do the three
shock on it
dude this is how much I just completely
jumped back in and I'm so wishy-washy we
go out the president of Guinness shows
up his Irish guy that just took over and
he's like I'd like to have a point with
you let's go out and talk you know and
we're just had this bar and he just like
puts down two beers and I'm like well I
have to drink this beer because this
dudes in front of me so I drink the beer
and then I'm like we have another one
and I'm like don't do a shot and he's
like I love to do a shot I go out and
get hammered with this guy like
hammered I ain't drank in five weeks and
I was like this sausage finger is
my new best friend he became I started
blacking out I'm gonna be at the DC
Draft House this weekend I can't go to
DC without thinking about what did the
Guinness shows
I got blackout drunk and just smoked
cigarettes in my hotel room like it was
the 70s and then a week later I called
the hotel and I was like look I did my
best
official white guy voice it was like odd
charge there's a strange charge and all
I did was to say this guy goes he has a
cleaning fee I think he smoked your room
I go that's funny I don't smoke Oh
that's weird hmm hmm yeah catch-22 today
I was in the back they always have to
give it back have you called out I
didn't smoke in my room doing your
neighbor called me a smoker you're
[Music]
stressing me the yeah we gonna
cigarette I mean I don't even smoke yeah
it was bad call me a smoker
that's my ears and then I was taking
that drinking energy on the road when I
was doing comedy nice ODEs McKenzie to
hell yeah
Duffman that's what my friends called me
so knapsack full of Hawaiian
shirts and jams
dude you ready to party all you need is
a Miller oh I you know this thing about
Hawaiian shirts it's day gear and sleep
gear yeah it's pajama jams and day jams
it was can't see puke on a weird
landscape shirt Guinness is owned by
this company named Diageo and they're
like a major alcohol company they own
like johnnie walker or Jose Cuervo
Smirnoff they own like most major brands
they have an office over on 45th and
fifth and if you're an employee they
have a full bar Lou don't use in your
pants you can walk in and you're not
allowed to tip the bartender they need
an engineer you can drink whatever you
want so I would be like always if you're
an employee of Diageo you can go have a
drink at the bar when you want of
anything so I wouldn't just had Johnny
Walker Blue like at the bar just like
all right and then by the way it was
Monday nights Kristen just creamed her
jeans yeah but that was a Monday night
when I was doing a show at Caroline's
and I showed up drunk to Caroline's
those like whatever I am and they're
like it's 9:00 how are you this drunk
and I was like oh like five o'clock and
you don't tip you just sit the only time
did the most awkward thing in my life
was and you'll know this is a cigarette
smoker was leaving to go smoke a
cigarette and trying to get back in
without looking like a right
I gotta have a Guinness black
it's Christine here I was that was the
girl that I knew that worked there was
Kristen and I was like his cattle
Kristen do she's totally cool I mean
back in you're trying to grab the door
back it close you put your foot in
that's just something mean the end of
your bartender no we're friends
cool I think that's my wall
give me one thing I'm meeting you
halfway the most pathetic weekends in my
life for where I was on the road and I
was like I'm not drinking this weekend
and then you're talking like that and
you know like you have media in four
hours and you're like you're the one
who's media whatever I'm gonna
wake up fresh as a daisy then you wake
up and everything sideways so I go puke
this okay ah sorry our guest things be a
weird this is woody in the scoot I'm
feeling this why don't you guys turns
microphones off flushes Peter go
can we talk like we did when I walked in
I will get a little uncomfortable or is
gonna get Dan show this I don't even
want to do a show I want to get a little
college with you so I'm gonna show you
me come back with five tickets for Dan
Soder he's gonna be the funny mode don't
know what his acts about you've seen him
on the guy code he's a little out of it
right now show you me to show you
[Music]
you